Peggy 18
who is Morgan you that's one of the
questions you'll be answering because
when the game begins you have no idea
why you're on the space station what
people were doing to you how you got
there what you need to do to get out of
the situation hello Morgan
tough day right I'm talking to myself it
must be in play you can play either male
or female version of Morgan ago we
wanted you to identify with the
character as much as possible we did not
want to impose personalities such as the
cocky extrovert or the cynical introvert
the player has a large role in defining
the Morgan is Morgan is at a point in
her life where she's having an identity
crisis and it's up to the player to help
guide Morgan along one path or another
to define which version of Morgan you
want to see you as a player go into it
completely unknown she's leaving
information for you your memory shot
full of holes
I know I'm sorry but it's permanent you
are traveling through her life and
discovering bits about her relationships
with the other individuals who were on
the station and how those relationships
played out whatever you are ready Morgan
and what you quickly discover is that
you're at the center of an experiment
that's meant to alter what it means to
be human
very quickly you discover that things
are not well won't tell us one things
have gone sideways there's this species
of alien called the typhoon that have
overrun everything some of them are
actually hunting you and you'll have to
use everything at your disposal your
wits and your creativity as a player the
tools and weapons that you find laying
around the station and then possibly
powers one of the choices that you have
to make is how much alien power you want
to invest in more you do the more
where of you there's an alien called
nightmare that has been designed to
chase you basically to meet you he will
appear more often also the turrets will
attack you because they won't recognize
you as an alien entity then there are
other choices based on what you want to
do with the characters of the space
station some of them are going to ask
you for favors you can do them or not do
them you go get something of mine huh
it will influence the way the game
unravels and also to influence the
endings breaking convention is in our
blood as you move through the space
station you'll find out that you have a
history with a lot of the people that
you meet that are still alive a lot of
the gadgets objects items that you
discover you had a role in even
inventing them but even more importantly
your brother Alex you is the CEO of
Transtar and a lot of things aboard the
station are the way they are as a result
of your relationship with it
Morgan's choices matter how Morgan
treats the people around her and what
Morgan does to respond to the aliens
evading the station matter the way that
I play Morgan you really depends on the
day that I'm playing there's so many
different ways and sometimes I want to
approach the game from a different
perspective than on other days there's a
lot of opportunities to either play as
epicly as possible or perhaps as an
enemy just be yourself
all of these things contribute to
different permutations of end games that
we have so it matters that way but it
also matters how the other characters
respond to you and how to treat you and
it's exactly what will define Morgan in
the end the only thing that matters is
how you treat the people that are still
alive
[Music]